[Musique]
le monde
la légende raconte que chi ram le bon
roi des indes a rendu au fil de l'épée
son pays riche prospère et respecté et
que maintenant le bon vieux roi n'a plus
rien à faire ils s'ennuient alors pour
le guérir de sa mélancolie son ministre
qui s'appelle ses seins à l'idée
d'inventer un jeu qui permettent de
simuler la guerre le jeu des échecs et
le miracle se produit le roi se
passionne pour les échecs et retrouve sa
joie de vivre alors pour remercier son
ministre il lui dit demande moi ce que
tu veux et je te le donnerai
alors c'est ça répond
je veux un grain de blé pour la première
case de l'échiquier puis 2 gr pour la
deuxième puis 4 pour la troisième puis 8
pour la quatrième et ainsi de suite en
doublant le nombre de grains de blé sur
chaque cas jusqu'à la 64e et dernière
droit cet homme mais bon il fait venir
ses comptables et des comptables
commence à compter un + 2 us 4 au début
tout va bien c'est la sphère de quelques
sacs et puis au bout de quelques cases
on parle plutôt en grenier à blé complet
et vient le moment où les comptables
réalise que le nombre de grains à
rassembler si grand que jamais on ne
pourra en rassembler assez même si la
terre entière était en semences et de
blé de l'orient à l'occident et du midi
ou septentrion même après des siècles de
récolte
dans un manuscrit persan du 14e siècle
qui raconte une des versions de cette
légende le roi s'incline devant son
ministre et lui cède le trône ce à quoi
ça répond j'ai gagné ton estime cela
vaut plus que tous les trésors nous
sommes quittes
il y a énormément de choses à dire sur
cette légende sur tout un tas de sujets
notamment le fait que depuis au moins un
millénaire qu on la raconte
la façon dont on l'a dit dit des choses
sur la façon dont nous voyons le monde
au début
pendant un certain temps ces histoires
de blain de grains qui doublait sur
l'échiquier ont trouvé ça plutôt bien
c'était une sorte de promesse
d'abondance notamment agricoles et puis
les choses ont commencé à changer à la
toute fin du 19e siècle notamment sous
l'impulsion de thomas malthus qui est
l'auteur en 1798 d'un ouvrage qui
s'appelle essai sur le principe de
population où il explique que et bien la
démographie humaine selon lui est
systématiquement galopante et finit
toujours par créer des problèmes de
famine de surpopulation et pour
justifier pour expliquer pour illustrer
cette démographie galopante humaine il
utilise dès le début de son essai dès le
premier chapitre une illustration
mathématiques fait de cette suite 1 2 4
8 et c'est assez la même suite que celle
des grains sur l'échiquier
malthus a eu et a encore beaucoup des
héritiers spirituels et notamment pour
parler de la section population mais
aussi de ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
s'en sortir selon malthus la solution
est bien c'est de laisser crever les
pauvres dans leur misère tout simplement
parce que ce sont les pauvres qui sont
mal éduqués ce sont les pauvres qui font
des enfants des enfants encore des
enfants et qui nous étouffe alors à
chaque fois qu'on les aide il continue à
nous étouffer
les élites et de malthus propose un peu
le même genre de solution même s'ils le
disent autrement et des solutions qui
s'exprime de façon un peu détournée mais
toujours aussi équivoque
vous avez remarqué mais à chaque fois
qu'il est question de dire qu'il ya trop
de monde sur la terre c'est toujours se
faire l'afrique qu'on se tourne et il
est très rare que l'on se dise mais
tiens c'est quand même un peu c'est une
musique un petit peu dérangeante
pourquoi on ne dit pas ça que c'est
dérangeant pour des raisons évidentes et
bien l'une des raisons tient à la façon
dont nous racontons aujourd'hui la
légende des grains sur l'échiquier ou
tout autre les gens tout autre toute
autre histoire tout autre récit du même
genre qui met en scène la croissance
exponentielle où la croissance
géométriques ce seront deux termes
synonymes pour nous c'est à dire ou bien
les grains se multiplient
la façon dont on raconte cette histoire
aujourd'hui et relève de ce qu'on peut
appeler la mystique de l'expo l'ancienne
on commence par vous raconter cette
histoire le roi des indes etc et puis
on vous humilie c'est la première étape
on vous demande combien ça va faire de
gras en tout à alesi proposer quelque
chose 1 millions 10 millions vous dites
100 millions propos vous êtes loin du
compte
c'est beaucoup plus or qu'est-ce que
vous êtes nuls
ensuite on zack wright considère on vous
sidère c'est à dire qu'on vous donne le
nom de l'hôtel de grains total que ça
fait sans vous dire évidemment comment
la trouver et on insiste pour dire que
c'est un nombre immense et ça vous fige
et enfin on sacralise c'est à dire qu'on
vous fait bien comprendre que tout ça ça
vous dépasse c'est trop fort pour vous
vous y arriverez pas nous allons donc
les grands nombres n'essayez pas de
comprendre au fond vous êtes trop petit
de vente et donc on apprend d'une
certaine façon à craindre les grands
nombres est à craindre l'exponentielle
et avec la crainte viennent les peurs
irrationnelles
et avec elles parfois les idées dont on
ne se rend même pas compte qu'elles sont
mauvaises
pour surmonter sa peur une technique
bien connue bien ancienne celle qu'on
appelle de l'exposition vous avez peur
des araignées bien regarder une araignée
regarde une photo approchez-vous petit à
petit essayer d'apprivoiser l'objet de
votre peur on devrait faire pareil avec
les grands nombres
apprivoiser les grands nombres pour se
souvenir que on peut les manier et la
légende des grains donne une très bonne
occasion de le faire
alors on va le faire ensemble on va
compter combien il y a deux grains sur
l'échiquier et comme il s'agit de
s'exposer on va pas prendre de
calculatrices imam de feuilles ou de
crayon on va le faire entièrement de
tête d'une soirée sur le courage alors
j'espère que j'aurai pas peur d'un petit
cours de maths
anosy
tout d'abord
on va écrire le nombre de grains sur
chaque case alors au début c'est assez
facile
un grain sur la première puis 2 sur la
deuxième et ensuite on double à chaque
fois donc sur la case suivante c'est 2
fois 2 ce qui fait
quatre très bien ensuite on multiplie à
nouveau x 2
8 x 2
16 x 2
32 x 2
64 c'est bien x
228 x 2
256 vous la connaissez bien fois de
encore
512 x 2 si le 1024 voilà on a fini on a
fini le plus difficile de tous nos
calculs maintenant on va plutôt
raisonner parce qu'on va pas continuer
comme ça a multiplié par 2 rassurez vous
pour écrire la suite on va utiliser la
notation exponentielle sur la case
suivante on a 2 x 2 x 2 x 2 11 fois le
facteur 2 on l'écrit deux puissances 11
puis sur la case suivante on aura un
facteur de supplémentaires ça fera deux
puissances 12 et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à la dernière la 64e case sur
laquelle on écrira donc deux puissances
63 j'ai entendu très bien pas 64 il ya
un petit décalage de puissance 11 c'est
pour la 12è case de puissance 12 pour la
treizième car il ya un petit décalage
est donc maintenant on doit faire la
somme de tous les nombres qui sont
écrits ici alors pour le faire on va
prendre un échiquier plus petit on va
dire on va regarder ce qui se passe
uniquement pour trois cases un + 2 + 4
ça ça fait 7 c'est très facile à voir
est ce qu'il faut remarquer c'est que
cette ses 8 - 1 ou 2 8 c'est le nombre
de grains sur la case suivante
pareil si je prends les quatre premières
cases un plus de plus la pluie suite ça
fait 15 c 16 -
est-ce que ça continue la réponse est
oui on peut le constater comme ça mais
on peut aussi le démontrer alors on peut
illustrer la démonstration à l'aide du
cas suivants 1 plus de plus 4 + 8 + 16
c1 plus de +4 +8 +16 et un plus de +4 +8
on vient de voir à l'étape précédente
que c'était 16 - donc un plus de +4 plus
fluide plus 16 c 16 - 1
+ 16 autrement dit deux fois 16 -
et deux fois 16 c'est le double du
nombre de grammes sur la sur la case où
il y en a 16 ses deux puissants 5 et
donc on a bien démontré plutôt que
vérifier que le nombre de grains
la somme de guédé gras sur les premières
cases et bien donné par le nombre de
grains sur la case suivante à un
grimperait le raisonnement se
propagerait de case en case ainsi de
suite jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à là toute la
64e casu canton sommera tous ces grains
et bien on aura le nombre de grains sur
l'hypothétique 65e case qui aurait deux
puissances 64 grave d'où le total qui
nous intéresse depuis 160 4 - 1 voilà le
nombre de grains voilà une expression du
nombre total de grains sur l'échiquier
on a déjà pas mal avancé parce qu'on a
une expression assez ramassé assez
compact assez mathématisée c'est
intéressant mais ça reste encore un peu
abstrait est-ce que de puissants 64
moins-7 un grand nombre où est ce que
c'est un très grand nombre ou est ce que
c'est un très très grand nombre pour
l'instant on ne sait pas alors eh bien
il faut travailler encore un petit peu
depuis 164 voilà l'expression que ça
tonne
six rangées de 10 une rangée de 4 la
première rangée de 10 on a déjà calculé
on l'a déjà calculé ça faisait 1024 vous
vous souvenez ensuite eh bien la
deuxième ligne vaudra elle aussi 1024 de
la troisième série la quatrième série
et ainsi de suite et la dernière 2 x 2 x
2 x 2 c'est donc voilà une façon plus
compact d'écrire depuis 164 là si on
essaye de le faire de tête ça va
commencer à devenir compliqué on se
souvient alors que ce qui nous intéresse
ce n'est pas d'eux d'avoir une valeur
exacte mais une valeur approché on veut
savoir en gros combien il ya de gras à
ce qu'il ya dans quelle mesure le nombre
est grand et donc on va faire
l'hypothèse enfin on va faire la proxima
sionko 1024 ça n'est pas très différent
et donc depuis 164 n'est pas très
différent de mille fois mille fois mille
fois mille fois mille fois mille fois 16
et ça on sait le faire de tête c'est
très facile mais il faut à 1000
un million famine
1 milliard fois milles 1 mille milliards
de mille sabords tirer le capitaine
haddock dans les chaises longues de
numération que celles qu'on utilise en
français c'est un billion x 1001
billiard x 1000 1 trillion fois 16-16
three lions et voilà 1,1 1,6 18 d euros
derrière on a tout ce qu'on peut vouloir
savoir sur le nombre et on a travaillé
entièrement de tête aussi vous voulez le
veut la vraie valeur que vous la donner
c'est la calculer 18 trillions 446
milliards 744 millions 76 milliards 7
sur 9 millions 551 1616 ça vous
l'impression une peut-être
ça me fait plaisir d'être applaudi mais
en vrai que ce n'est pas un témoignage
de grande intelligence d'aligner des
chiffres comme ça vous voyez bien que ce
n'est pas si différent 16 three lions ou
dit un peu plus 18 trillions c'est un
grand effort de calculer ses 18
trillions et quelques alors qu' il n'y a
pratiquement rien à faire pour nous ces
intrusions le fait qu'il n'y a rien à
faire ça veut dire que et bien on peut
avoir accès au grand nombre avec un
petit peu de raisonnement ça n'est pas
mystique ça ne nous échappe pas alors
bien sûr ça vous a peut être paru un peu
rapide j'en ai bien conscience si vous
êtes un peu loin des mathématiques il ya
peut-être quelques points qui sont allés
trop vite c'est peut-être aussi le cas
si vous avez eu peur si vous vous êtes
dit au début le savez des maths c'est
pas pour moi la wii mais sinon en
réalité il n'ya rien de vraiment
difficile et donc il n'ya pas lieu de
faire des grands nombres une mystique
une fois qu'on a compris ça on peut
regarder les choses d'une façon un petit
peu différente sur certains sur certains
pourraient par exemple
voici une publication scientifique qui a
été fait en 2007 par james en scène
james hansen c'est un scientifique
américain un membre de l'académie
américaine des sciences quelqu'un de
très reconnue et qui est notamment connu
pour avoir été celui qui a lancé à
l'échelle politique et médiatique la
peur du réchauffement climatique
d'origine humaine avec son cortège de
catastrophes et de cataclysme qui nous
attendent notamment la hausse du niveau
marin
donc dans cette publication scientifique
de 2007 en scène nous annonce que la mer
va monter de 5 mètres d'ici la fin du
siècle 5 m ça c'est sidérant ça c'est un
nombre sidérant comment arrive-t-il à 5
m eh bien il nous dit ceci disons que la
contribution de la calotte glaciaire et
de 1 cm pour la décennie 2005 2015 et
qu'elles doublent chaque décennie cela
produit une hausse du niveau des mers de
l'ordre de 5 mètres pour ce siècle
alors une fois qu'on est plus sidéré et
dont on peut regarder comment il fait et
comme il fait c'est simplement que il a
vu un centimètre sur la première
décennie de son échiquier et il a
consciencieusement doublé sur chaque
case suivante jusqu'à la fin du siècle
alors comme on a vu pour faire la somme
ensuite au regard de la case suivante on
retranche 1 et on obtient 5 111 5 cm
voilà les cinq mètres
évidemment la question qui se pose une
fois qu'on a qu'on a cessé d'être
victime de la mystique qu'on n'est pas
sidéré par la grandeur du nombre on peut
se demander est ce que c'est vraiment
comme ça que la mer va monter ce qu est
ce que ce modèle simple représente la
réalité si ça peut vous rassurer la
réponse est non puisque aujourd'hui les
mais les scénarios les plus pessimistes
ne dépasse pas une soixantaine de
centimètres ce qui est quand même
beaucoup plus loin que l'apocalypse
celui qui a compris ça le premier
c'est karl marx cette histoire de
mystique de l'expo n'en ciel répondant à
un auteur anglais de la fin du xviiie
siècle qui s'appelait richard price
price avait écrit ceci un penny un
centime placé lors de la naissance de
notre sauveur jésus à 5% d'intérêts
composés aurait avant notre époque cru
jusqu'à atteindre une somme plus grandes
que celles qui seraient contenues dans
200 millions de fois tout lors de la
terre
nous c'est sidérant c'est magnifique
fondamentalement les intérêts composés
ça marche comme les grains ça se
multiplient un petit peu de la même
façon réponse de karl marx les
élucubrations fantaisistes du docteur
price dépasse de loin celle des
alchimistes price a simplement été
ébloui par la grandeur des nombres
auxquelles conduisent les progression
géométrique
en deux phrases il a tout dit c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs qu'il fasse
allusion à l'alchimie qui du point de
vue historique est effectivement une
mystique à une mystique dangereuse
qui peut avoir de terribles conséquences
qu'on ne mesure pas très bien comme on a
été rejoint par sa dans l'actualité
samedi dernier avec l'attentât qui s'est
produit à buffalo qui a été connue par
commis par un certain peyton jones était
pas de lui dont j'avais l'intention de
vous parler mais plutôt de celui dont il
s'est inspiré qui est brenton tharonne
ce qui est celui qui a commis l'attentât
en nouvelle-zélande en 2019 où il a
assassiné à l'armé automatique une
cinquantaine de musulmans qui avait le
tort des musulmans et torrent a laissé
un manifeste pour expliquer pourquoi il
a fait ça et l'essentiel est contenue
dans le tout début ils nous disent ceci
se traduit en français c'est le taux de
natalité c'est le taux de natalité c'est
le taux de natalité
c'est tous ces musulmans qui se
reproduisent plus vite que nous que nous
autres et qui vont nous en nous
engloutir alors john john a repris à peu
près la même chose des modélistes un peu
différente mais l'esprit est à peu près
le même
et donc bon il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire sûrement sur le psychisme de ternay
de john john mais un aspect du
diagnostic je pense est celui qui est
posée par karl marx ils sont éblouis par
la grandeur des nombres auxquelles
conduisent les progression géométrique
et ils en ont peur
cette peur est une peur d'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas la survivance de deux vieilles
superstitions qui à l'heure de
l'ordinateur vont finir par disparaître
pas du tout au contraire on a des textes
de l'antiquité qui nous donne qui nous
disent le contraire par exemple un texte
une biographie du bouddha qui nous
ramène en inde qui est en quelque sorte
le pays des grands nombres en plus
d'être le pays du bon roi qui rame où on
voit le bouddha faire un calcul un petit
peu équivalent à celui des grains sur
l'échiquier et on voit la foule qui
l'applaudît et ce qui est frappant dans
ce passage c'est que la foule applaudit
non pas le mystère des grands nombres
mais la capacité à calculer avec eux
alors la prochaine fois qu'on essaie de
vous impressionner avec la mystérieuse
exponentielle et ses courbes qui monte à
l'infini
pourrait penser à ce que faisait bouddha
c'est à dire qu'il commençait à faire le
calcul sans avoir peur et ensuite songer
à karl marx et au fait qu'il est
important de ne pas se laisser éblouir
inconsidérément une fois qu'on se
débarrasse de la peur irrationnelle des
grands nombres et aussi de la naïveté à
leur sujet eh bien on peut commencer à y
réfléchir
vrai merci
[Applaudissements]